[Music]
this is what Israel calls a targeted
killing but the attack on Khalid
al-bahatini commander of the Palestinian
armed group Islamic Jihad wasn't so
targeted also killed was his wife Layla
his four-year-old daughter hijad as well
as two sisters living nearby Iman and
Dania are this
eleven-year-old sister NADA survived her
attack in Gaza her emotions are still
raw
I was under the rubble I was shouting
for them for one hour eventually they
pulled me from the rubble and I found
out that they had all died father wasn't
around all the time but when he was home
I was so happy I'm very sad and mad
about Israel yes Baba was a mujahid a
fighter but why did they do this to us
why did they kill my sister and my
mother they took from me the ones I
loved the most
none of the family denied that Khalid
al-bahatini was a member of Islamic
Jihad after this latest Gaza War the
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu
described the so-called shield and arrow
operation as perfect but there were
reports from human rights groups and
local media reports here in Israel that
the Israeli Army knew that civilians
would be targeted but they went ahead
with the operation anyway
two groups the public Committee Against
torture in Israel and Yash gavil are
demanding that the Attorney General
forced the state of Israel to
investigate civilian deaths a Supreme
Court ruling to do so already exists but
it isn't enforced targeted killings are
legal according to the Supreme Court if
certain conditions are met one of those
conditions is avoiding civilian
casualties as much as possible enforcing
the Supreme Court ruling to investigate
isn't happening and human rights lawyer
tell Steiner wants that to change but
understands it's a tough battle so if in
the past Israel would execute a targeted
killing and civilians were killed it
would at least show some remorse and
express its regret
maintained that it was not the the aim
this is not something that we've seen in
those targeted killings on the contrary
Israel has referred to them as
surgically precise attacks not even
trying to to show remorse for the the
the loss of Civilian lives Israel's
attorney general Gali baharav miara says
she will respond to the group's letter
demanding an independent investigation
meanwhile the government continues its
policy of targeted killings seemingly
with no questions asked Imran Khan Al
Jazeera West Jerusalem